well police and Hamburg say they were
called at around 9 15 p.m after reports
of shots being fired in the gross Boston
District of the city they believe that
one of the bodies found on an upper
floor of the building in Deal buga
Street may have been the perpetrator our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
reports and her report starts with
images of the gunman
in Hamburg in the shadows a figure by a
window
gunfire rings out
here an alleged perpetrator caught on
camera
those shots are fired at people inside a
Jehovah's Witness Meeting Hall
um
I'm a resident up here and I heard loud
gunshots so I went to the window to get
an idea of the situation then I saw that
a man was shooting out of the window
with a firearm
there were people being carried out and
there were probably 25 shots at least
that I heard
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
it was just after nine o'clock when
police were called to the building in
the gross borstall District inside a
truly horrific scene
the police officers who went in there
then also found people who have been
seriously injured by firearms and some
fatally injured the officers themselves
then also heard another shot from the
upper parts of the property and went
upstairs and found another person there
as well
officers believe a person they found
fatally wounded upstairs may have been
the attacker but the motive for the
shooting is still unclear
hamburg's mare tweeted the reports from
ulsterdorf are shocking I extend my
deepest sympathy to the families of the
victims
[Music]
police are still trying to work out
exactly what happened what sparked an
act of mass violence which has left a
city morning